so element 96 was curium which was named
after Marie Curie and Pierre Curie who
are the discoverers of radium because of
its high levels of radioactivity curium
can be used in thermoelectric generators
there to produce electricity and you'll
get about 120 watts per hour out of one
of these however because it is so
radioactive no one's really interested
in using in commercial processes well
past uranium
everything is synthetically made you
need access to nuclear power stations or
nuclear bombs or big colliders to be
able to make these elements they're
extremely radioactive very hard to
handle and only a handful of places in
the UK have got the sort of facilities
you need to deal with these types of
compounds so even somebody such as
myself it's not really what I do it's a
little bit beyond where my area is I've
pretty much stopped at uranium that's
the limit of normal laboratory chemistry